LET'S GET STRAIGHT TO CNN'S JEFF
ZELENY LIVE IN ATLANTA WITH THE
LATEST.
JEFF, A VERY TIGHT RACE DOWN
THERE.
>> Reporter: ALEX, GOOD MORNING.
YOU COULD HEAR THE CONCERN THERE
AND SEE THE CONCERN FROM SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER.
THAT REFLECTS WHAT DEMOCRATS
HERE IN GEORGIA ARE SAYING AS
WELL.
THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
SENATE RACE IN SO MANY OTHER
PLACES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHY FORMER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA IS
BEGINNING HIS WEEK-LONG PUSH AND
RALLYING DEMOCRATS AND PUSHING
THEM TO THE POLLS.
>> YOU HAVE THE POWER TO CHANGE
AMERICA.
>> Reporter: BARACK OBAMA IS
HEADING BACK TO THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, FIRING UP DEMOCRATS IN
THE FINAL PUSH FOR THE FALL
ELECTION.
>> HELLO ATLANTA.
>> Reporter: STARTING IN GEORGIA
HE'S HITTING AT LEAST FIVE
STATES HOPING TO STOP OR SLOW
THE PROSPECT OF A REPUBLICAN
WAVE IN NOVEMBER.
IT'S FAMILIAR TERRAIN FOR THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WHO FOR WEEKS
HAS BEEN POPPING UP IN
TELEVISION ADS AND CAMPAIGN
VIDEOS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> PENNSYLVANIA, IT'S UP TO YOU.
YOU CAN COUNT ON JOHN FETTERMAN.
GRETCHEN WHIT MMER IS MICHIGAN
TOUGH.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A CLOSE
RACE.
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO GET IT WRONG.
VOTE DEMOCRAT ON NOVEMBER 8th.
>> Reporter: HE'S STILL ONE OF
THE MOST POPULAR FIGURES IN HIS
PARTY GOING WHERE PRESIDENT
BIDEN IS FAR LESS WELCOME BY
DEMOCRATS THIS YEAR.
>> I AM FIRED UP.
ARE YOU FIRED UP?
>> Reporter: OF COURSE, IT
WASN'T ALWAYS THAT WAY.
LIKE WHEN OBAMA FACED A
PUNISHING MID-TERM ELECTION OF
HIS OWN IN 2010 LOSING 63
STOOETS AND CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE, 6 SENATE SEATS AND
DEVASTATING DEFEATS IN STATE
CAPITOLS.
>> I'M NOT RECOMMENDING FOR
EVERY PRESIDENT THAT THEY TAKE A
SHELLACKING LIKE I DID LAST
NIGHT.
YOU KNOW, I'M SURE THERE ARE
EASIER WAYS TO LEARN THESE
LESSONS.
>> Reporter: AND AGAIN IN 2014.
>> OBVIOUSLY REPUBLICANS HAD A
GOOD NIGHT AND THEY DESERVE
CREDIT FOR RUNNING GOOD
CAMPAIGNS.
>> Reporter: HIS TRACK RECORD
HAS BEEN FAR BETTER WHEN HIS OWN
NAME IS ON THE BALLOT BUT HE'S
ANSWERING THE CALL FROM
DEMOCRATS.
HIS ITINERARY BEGINS WITH
GEORGIA FOLLOWED BY MICHIGAN AND
WISCONSIN ON SATURDAY.
NEVADA ON TUESDAY.
CONGRESSWOMAN NIKENA WILLIAMS
SAID OBAMA HAS A UNIQUE ABILITY
TO MOTIVATE AND MAKE THE CASE
FOR DEMOCRATS.
>> WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GO OUT AND
VOTE EARLY.
HE CAN HELP US DRIVE THAT
MESSAGE HOME AND DRIVE HOME
WHAT'S AT STAKE FOR NOT JUST OUR
BASE BUT YOUNGER VOTERS WHO
REMEMBER SOME OF THE EXCITEMENT
AROUND HIS ELECTION.
>> Reporter: OBAMA IS HITTING A
HANDFUL OF STATES WITH
COMPETITIVE RACES TARGETING NOT
ONLY CONTESTS THAT WILL HELP
DETERMINE CONTROL OF THE HOUSE
AND SENATE BUT ALSO CAMPAIGNS
FOR GOVERNOR AND SECRETARY OF
STATE, ROLES THAT OFTEN OVERSEE
ELECTIONS.
>> IT'S A REMINDER DEMOCRACY IS
FRAGILE.
YOU HAVE TO TEND TO IT AND FIGHT
FOR IT.
>> Reporter: PROTECTING
DEMOCRACY IS A KEY FOCUS.
ADVISERS SAY IT WILL BE A
CENTRAL MESSAGE FOR VOTERS AT
HIS CAMPAIGN RALLIES.
>> HELLO, EVERYBODY.
>> Reporter: HIS TRAVELS COME
AFTER ALREADY CASTING HIS FORMAL
BALLOT WHICH THEY DID IN
CHICAGO.
>> I WANT TO PUNCH IT.
IT WAS FUN.
THAT WAS FUN.
GET OUT SOME PRESSURE.
>> Reporter: IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
MID-TERM ELECTIONS WERE NEVER
ACTUALLY BARACK OBAMA'S STRONG
SUIT.
THE SHELLACKING THE DEMOCRATS
RECEIVED.
OF COURSE, THEY HOPE THAT IS NOT
A REPLAY THIS YEAR, BUT THE
REALITY IS DEMOCRATS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE HOUSE AND
INDEED THE SENATE.
IT IS WHY MR. OBAMA COMING TO
GEORGIA TRYING TO FIRE UP
DEMOCRATS.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE GETTING OUT
THE VOTE AND HE BEGINS THAT HERE
IN ATLANTA.
>> MAJOR FEARS OF A SHELLACKING.
JEFF ZELENY IN ATLANTA, THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
>>> JOINING US NOW, CNN'S CHIEF
POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT AND HOST
OF "STATE OF THE UNION" DANA
BASH.
>> PEOPLE ARE -- THIS IS
BREAKING NEWS BECAUSE YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN COVERING THIS AT
ALL ON THIS SHOW.
PEOPLE ARE REALLY, REALLY
ANXIOUS, REALLY ANXIOUS.
YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT THIS, HOW MANY CAMPAIGNS
HAVE WE COVERED WHERE WE FOCUS
ON GAS PRICES, SORT.
OF THE ISSUES WHERE THEY GO,
UGH.
I HAVE NOT HAD THE SENSE LIKE I
HAVE NOW THAT PEOPLE ARE AGAIN U
WINLY WORRIED ABOUT THE KITCHEN
TABLE THINGS.
EGGS UP 30%, ALL OF THE THINGS
IN THEIR LIVES.
IF YOU GO UP A NOTCH, I'VE SPENT
TIME WITH SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS,
IT'S THEM TRYING TO NOT JUST
MAKE PAYROLL BUT ALSO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT IF THEY RAISE THEIR
PRICES BECAUSE ALL OF THEIR
EXPENSES ARE HIGHER, SO ON, SO
FORTH.
IT'S LITTLE REALLY IN THE FACT
OF EVERYDAY LIES.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER OR NOT
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE HISTORICALLY
ON THE FENCE GOING TO TAKE THAT
BALLOT AND USE IT AS A WEAPON
AGAINST THE PEOPLE IN POWER JUST
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO ANGRY AND SO
ANXIOUS.
>> OF COURSE, SO MUCH HANGING IN
THE BALANCE FOR DEMOCRATS.
AS WE'VE GOTTEN CLOSER TO
ELECTION DAY, SO MANY OF THESE
RACES HAVE TIGHTEND UP.
THE SENATE RACE IN OHIO.
THE SENATE RACE IN GEORGIA.
THE GUBERNATORIAL RACE IN NEW
YORK.
DID YOU EXPECT IT TO COME DOWN
TO THE WIRE THE WAY THAT IT IS?
>> KIND OF BECAUSE A LOT OF
THESE STATES, GEORGIA, ARIZONA.
WE'VE SEEN THIS SO MANY TIMES
WHERE THOSE RACES SOMETIMES ARE
NOT CALLED FOR DAYS, EVENLY
LONGER.
EVEN NEW HAMPSHIRE THE INCUMBENT
DEMOCRAT, MAGGIE HASSAN, PEOPLE
THOUGHT ONCE DON BULDOC WON THE
PRIMARY, HE SWITCHED HIS TUNE
BUT IN THE PRIMARY HE WAS VERY
MUCH AN ELECTION DENIER, VERY
TRUMPY.
THAT WORKS BUT NOT LIKE IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
REPUBLICANS ARE FEELING BULLISH
ABOUT IT.
WE'LL SEE.
IT'S BECAUSE OF WHAT WE TALKED
ABOUT BEFORE, BECAUSE OF THE
FEELING OUT THERE.
IT'S ALSO BECAUSE OF WHAT JEFF
WAS JUST REPORTING ON.
IT'S HISTORY.
IT'S JUST THE WAY THINGS TEND TO
BE, WHICH IS THE PARTY IN POWER,
THE PRESIDENT IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, TENDS TO LOSE SEATS,
SOMETIMES A LOT OF SEATS IN HIS
FIRST MID-TERM SO THIS IS MAYBE
GRAVITY TAKING HOLD.
WE'LL SEE.
A LOT OF THESE DEMOCRATS COULD
DEFINITELY COME OUT ON TOP AND
THAT IS WHY YOU'RE SEEING
PRESIDENT OBAMA IN PARTICULAR
OUT THERE REALLY TRYING TO BOOST
THE TURNOUT, BECAUSE THAT IS
WHAT MATTERS NOW.
IT'S CLICHE BUT IT'S CLICHE
BECAUSE IT HAPPENS TO BE TRUE.
TODAY IN PHILADELPHIA PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS ARE SET TO MAKE A RARE
APPEARANCE TOGETHER FOR JOHN
FETTERMAN IN THE PENNSYLVANIA
SENATE RACE.
THIS IS A BIG DISPLAY OF SUPPORT
FOR FETTERMAN.
>> IT IS.
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN AND VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS WILL BE
SPEAKING AT A FUND-RAISING
DINNER FOR THE PENNSYLVANIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, EXPECTED TO
RAISE ABOUT $1 MILLION FOR THEIR
PARTY THIS EVENING, BUT IT'S
ALSO GOING TO OFFER THE
PRESIDENT AN OPPORTUNITY TO ONCE
AGAIN REINFORCE HIS MESSAGING
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ECONOMY
SEEKING TO DRAW A CONTRAST WITH
REPUBLICANS ON THINGS LIKE
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS, SECRET
SERVICE -- SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE.
AND TAXES.
AND ALSO YESTERDAY PRESIDENT
BIDEN SPOKE ABOUT THE THREAT HE
BELIEVES REPUBLICANS POSE TO THE
ECONOMY IN THIS CASE RAISING THE
DEBT CEILING.
>> UNLESS WE YIELD TO THEIR
DEMANDS TO CUT SOCIAL SECURITY
AND MEDICARE, THEY'RE WILLING TO
TAKE DOWN THE ECONOMY OVER IT,
THERE IS NOTHING THAT WOULD
CREATE MORE CHAOS OR DO MORE
DAMAGE TO THE AMERICAN ECONOMY
IF THAT HAPPENS.
>> Reporter: THIS COMES AS THE
WHITE HOUSE IS AWARE OF THE
ECONOMIC ANXIETY SO MANY
AMERICANS ARE FEELING, THE
PRESIDENT TRYING TO LEAN IN TO
HIS ARGUMENTS THAT REPUBLICANS
POSE A GREATER THREAT TO THE
ECONOMY IF THEY TAKE CONTROL OF
THE HOUSE AND SENATE.
>> HOW MUCH MORE ARE WE GOING TO
SEE THE PRESIDENT ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAILS.
>> Reporter: TODAY MARKS THE
19th TRIP FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
THE COMMONWEALTH SINCE TAKING
OFFICE.
HE'LL BE HERE FOR JOHN FETTERMAN
AND SHA PPIRO AND OTHER
CANDIDATES.
NEXT WEEK HE'LL TRAVEL DOWN TO
FLORIDA, A STATE HE'S BEEN
TRYING TO MAKE AN APPEARANCE AT
FOR QUITE SOME TIME, THE FIRST
ONE CANCELLED WHEN HE HAD COVID
AND THE OTHER WHEN HE HAD COVID.
HE'LL BE CAMPAIGNING THERE WITH
CHARLEY CHRIST.
LATER IN THE WEEK HE'LL GO TO
NEW MEXICO, A STATE YOU DON'T
TYPICALLY SEE THE PRESIDENT
GOING TO.
HE'S EXPECTED TO HAVE AN
APPEARANCE IN PENNSYLVANIA IN
THAT FINAL WEEKEND OF THE
CAMPAIGN AS HE IS TRYING TO
BOOST THOSE CANDIDATES THERE.
IN A STATE THEY FEEL THEY COULD
BE HELPFUL TO DEMOCRATS.
>> VERY BUSY FEW DAYS AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.